unknown to many
the Grand Mosque of Paris
the Grand Mosque of Paris is a wonderful
structure on the left bank it is the
central focus of Islam in Paris and
indeed it is probably the most distinct
and important Muslim architectural
institution in all of Europe the Grand
Mosque was built in 1926 as a token of
gratitude for the 100,000 North African
Muslims who fought and died for France
in World War one it is a marvel of
design and beauty
[Music]
but there is another hidden facet of the
Grand Mosque a mysterious legend
whispered for decades but known only to
a few the details of individual cases
are very difficult to identify what are
the secrets locked inside the Grand
Mosque of Paris and what rule did this
house of worship play in one of the most
wrenching episodes in modern history
nine months into world war ii german
forces conquer france and set up the
Vichy government the collaborationist
regime assists in carrying out Adolf
Hitler's Nazi program which includes
rounding up Jews and sending them to
concentration camps
[Music]
to help carry out their plan the Nazis
attempt to recruit local Muslims the
Germans strategy was to try to reach out
to the significant Muslim community in
France to try to win them over to the
German side the Germans begin with
khador Benga breach a well-respected
Muslim elder and the head of the grand
mosque in public Benga breed is friendly
and cooperative with the Nazis but
privately he is hatching a secret and
dangerous plot the grand mosque will
hide Jews from the Nazis the mosque gave
Jews certificates of Muslim identity you
could pass as Muslim if you had this
birth certificate or certificate from
the mall while some Jews evade detection
with the fake documents the mosque
simply doesn't have enough to go around
so Ben GU breat ratchets things up this
time using the mosque itself the
underground pathways underneath the
mosque which led out to other streets
who other neighborhoods were places
where Jews and others were protected
Benga breeds plan to hide Jews in these
passageways is soon put to the test
there was one very celebrated testimony
from a gentleman named Alberto Celine
Celine a North African Jew escapes from
a German prisoner of war camp
after days of traveling in secret he
arrives in Paris and makes his way to
the Grand Mosque but in the Nazi
occupied city a Saleem is far from safe
while he and other Jews are hiding
inside German soldiers suddenly raid the
mosque the mosque would trigger a series
of lights that would flash when the
Germans were about to enter the premises
of the mosque and Jews would recognize
these lights and would find hiding
places within the catacombs behind
closet doors
ah Selene uses these catacombs to escape
Oh in his life to the Grand Mosque
but the mosques commitment to saving
Jews is about to face its greatest
challenge yet in wartime Paris a pop
singer named Celine Holly is a big hit
in town alali
was one of the most famous singers of
the day fairy this is like the Jewish
just to be Justin Bieber also a Jew and
when the Nazis decide to seize him the
Grand Mosque of Paris becomes his last
desperate hope for survival but can the
mosque help save one of the most famous
men in France
France the Grand Mosque of Paris at the
height of World War two the mosque is
secretly hiding Jews right under the
noses of the occupied Nazis there was a
natural willingness of some of the
leaders of the mosque to assist
countrymen who were facing severe
life-threatening danger because of the
Nazi occupation that danger extends to
the Muslims themselves including the
mosques leader to door been cabrito who
is about to put everything on the line
to help save someone seemingly
impossible to hide a flourish Geneva
singer named Salim halal II he was
Jewish from Algeria he thought that he
would be immune from the Germans because
he was so famous but of course he wasn't
Muslims are working as safe in them
ahead of luck and he got word that the
Germans were gonna come after
Ben could have been a Christian whoever
this is with human being that Muslims
are trying to say and then Ben Gabry
takes an even bolder step he had a
tombstone at the Muslim cemetery outside
Paris engraved with halal his father so
that halal he could say when the Germans
came after him see I'm I'm I'm Muslim
I'm not Jewish just go to check the
cemetery you'll see where my where my
father is buried surprisingly the Nazis
are fooled and halal a survives the war
and he to his dying day and you can
check the obituaries of Hawaii thanked
benka breed for saving his life
benda breed for his part keeps silent on
the mosques role in hiding Jews when he
dies in 1954 he is buried in a wall of
the mosque taking the secrets of the
rescue mission with him
today the Grand Mosque of Paris attracts
both worshippers and visitors from all
over the world and it's heroic efforts
still resonate for all who walk through
its doors it's a story that everybody
can appreciate because it's a universal
story rescue and protection at a time of
intense danger and that brings a very
faraway culture right at home as you
guys can see we have a lot to talk about
on this week's episode of the Deen show
Muslims being almost washed out of lot
of the history but when the history
comes to light from not Muslim sources
but from the not-yet Muslim sources you
see the truth manifesting and we're
going to be talking about many of those
truths on the DS show today and they're
based around reviving much of the way
the Sunna of the prophets who are sent
to mankind Jesus Moses Abraham the last
a fundamental problem ahom a piece of us
is upon him that is based on a man's
risa a Christian man's research that I'm
very interested to know much more about
he wrote a book and I'm here with a
person who is gonna tell us more about
this book that I'm sure that you're
gonna be interested to find out some of
these truths that are mentioned in the
book I'm curious to know I'm curious to
find out we got a lot to talk about on
this week's episode of the D show
salamualikum' how are you brother in
mind
welcome somebody I'm doing well how are
you we just handle ah I'm too loud we
just watched the clip we were talking
about it was talking about the Muslims
for the first part is very interesting
because you know there's a lot of
controversy that goes that's happening
in in Europe today and there's a lot of
hate rhetoric and you see that there was
a mosque that was built particularly in
France to honor Muslims for their role
that they played to help contribute to
saving France saving your saving Europe
right talk about this let's talk that's
that first part and then we'll get into
the other fascinating things that you
and I talked about these troops that
come out that many people are unaware of
that if they were to come out and we're
helping to bring them out this would
help to bridge you know to foster more
of this thing that we should be
fostering peace and unity instead of
this hate that's dividing a lot of us
based on a lot of misinformation and
just people's ignorance about Muslims in
Islam so what do you think what's that
mosques that they talked about in France
great question so I actually didn't know
about this history I didn't know about
the clip and I met a man by the name of
Luke farrier he's a Christian and his
grandfather fought in World War one as a
soldier from Belgium and he essentially
in his encounters with Muslims he wrote
a lot of diary entries about what he
thought about Muslims their honor their
integrity their respect so we'll get
back into that but in regards to this
specific story when I met Luke he
started telling me a lot of these
fantastical stories sometimes almost too
good to be true because we forgot in our
history so one of the stories that he
shared with me was about North African
soldiers who basically were the last
line of defense for France for Paris
when the Germans were trying to invade
anomaly's know the Nazis were world war
two okay yeah yeah this is just you know
the German forces from World War one and
because of these North African soldiers
they essentially as Luke has told me
they they were able to stop the Germans
from taking over France Muslims these
are Muslims Muslim soldiers and most of
them perished some of them survived but
even the ones that perished there's been
a monument there's been you know things
that have been built to honor them but
because of the ones that survived later
on they were honored and a mosque was
built as we saw in the video to honor
the the Muslim and the North African
contribution in World War one to save in
France so this mosque is built and the
Imam I believe at the time of World War
two was the son of one of the soldiers
from World War one now world war two
comes about the Nazis are invading again
they've come into France and as we saw
in the video the the mosque that was
built as a token of gratitude from the
French to the to the Muslims of North
Africa now the North African Muslims of
Paris are using to save people who are
Jewish I mean what kind of an amazing
story is that right it's goodness on top
of goodness diversity inclusion working
together humanity so when he told me
this I was astonished when Luc told me
this I was astonished I looked for the
proof he sent me you know I got the book
which we have right here I saw the
images I saw the quotations and then I
saw the Travel Channel clip and I was
stunned I said why don't we know this
yeah that's amazing you you're seeing
the Travel Channel they're talking about
how Muslims are saving human beings
right a human being right they happened
to be Jewish but they could have been
Christian or whoever else but this is
all bet based on the teachings of Islam
there's a verse in the Quran chapter 5
that talks about saving one innocent
human being is as as if you save the
world so Muslims are doing this because
this is what their way of life Islam
promotes and this is exactly what Luke's
grandfather alluded to in his diary and
this is also why I'm very impressed by a
man like Luke Ferry or someone who is
not Muslim but he has make it he's made
it a mission of his life to preserve our
history and it's a joint histories a
shared history but this is something
that he's always emphasizing that we
have to learn this history and he even
has a portion of the book dedicated
towards the teaching of Islam just a
page out of the whole book but even that
page it clears up a lot of the
misconceptions that people
right what Islam is not and what Islam
is and if you give me just a brief
second I would like to read a
translation and the summary of his
grandfather's original letter this is
his Greg his grandfather who fought yeah
who's also a devout Christian very
devout Christian as luke has told me a
very devout Christian someone who
believed in the faith and he his
original letter is written in I believe
Flemish yeah but Luke has translated it
and I have a summary of it now this is
the difference between say a devout
Christian who his he's he's nourishing
what the there's many Christians who
don't expose on much of this hate a
rhetoric right Jesus's message of peace
and love and he's he had a he made a
connection with Muslim he had that human
interaction right so this led him now to
what you're about to share with us yes
so let me just read it real quick I have
it here on my phone the translation is I
still cannot figure out why these
Muslims from overseas are fighting so
fiercely in a war that is not of their
concern they keep referring to their
religion and family traditions of honor
and loyalty many of them get wounded or
die because they never leave someone
behind
regardless of culture race or religion
we talk a lot about them happy to have
them on our side okay so now this is
Luke the author of this book his
grandfather writing this yes he's
writing this about he's he's and then
Luke finds this so writings let me tell
you this story so Luke never met his
grandfather and I think his story should
also be shared because again whether he
was a Christian a Jew a Hindu a Sikh it
doesn't matter he was an honest person
as far as we know and he spoke
truthfully right so world war two comes
around and Luke's grandfather's actually
put into a concentration camp by the
Nazis by the time he gets out of the
concentration camp he's never the same
and he dies shortly after and Luke
actually never got to meet him
so now last year or I'm sorry about
seven years ago Luke got interested in
this work he stumbles upon this diary in
his attic and he finds this this diary
full of his grandfather's experiences in
World War one
and it's so intense it's so deep it's so
personal but what surprises Luke is that
his grandfather is talking so positively
about Muslims number one Luke is
surprised he says I never knew Muslims
part took on the side of the Allies in
World War one and two there's such
positive superlatives such positive
adjectives that his grandfather is using
to describe Muslims so this basically
set Luke on a journey where he traveled
to I think nearly 20 countries he access
private collections he accessed military
archives libraries basements attics of
people's records of World War one and he
was blown away by the Muslim
contribution where did he get these
reports and and and these things of
documentation that were preserved
they're not from Muslim sources some of
them are a lot of them are military
archives from from the Allied countries
like you say Germany or France or
England some of them are people who have
them in their private collections so
he's made it a life's journey now to get
them authenticate them digitize them
preserve them and he's presented his
research at many academic settings he
was at Harvard last year yes he is going
to be at many places in the UK in Spain
and Dubai presenting a lot of his
findings but as far as I know and as far
as I've seen a lot of them he's tried
very hard to authenticate even there is
I think the British Army has attested to
some of the findings that even have
their own video about Muslim
contributions in World War one so pretty
amazing pretty amazing there's a couple
of things that so let's go back one
how's it go back a few pages there was
where one this picture right there
right yeah that's that's that's the one
it was one before that but here this is
interesting on here where I'll read it
says the reports this is from his book
the reports and letters mentioned that
Muslim soldiers shared their food with
the local people who were suffering from
famine in Europe so Muslims are feeding
the poor even though it's famine and he
talks about this despite the fact that
they knew it would weaken their own
strength
needed for the
fierce fighting to come very interesting
well you know there was a study I think
that in last year or two years ago I
forgot by which British entity and I
basically said that Muslims were either
the most charitable people in the UK or
one of the most this is by the UN this
came out okay I think last year yeah the
UN announced a so now we know we almost
Turkey they actually mentioned a country
it was Turkey the most charitable in the
world in the world but in the UK in the
UK yes yeah and so now think about it
what is it about Muslims that makes us
want to give charity it's our faith we
have many tenants of our faith many
sayings of the prophet salallahu alaihe
wasalam many verses of the quran that
talk about the benefits and the virtues
of giving charity right but now because
of also sincerity in class as we say in
arabic it's not something that we
necessarily want to talk about we try to
give without expecting anything in
return so now you have someone a soldier
from the subcontinent as far as I know
from his book that is in the war is in
France the provisions the rations are
going down but he finds these poor
countryside people these French people
and is giving some of his daily rations
to these people what would make someone
do something like this in a time of war
yeah why would he if Muslims hate people
right if they're in in that country and
they have their own food many people are
just just greedy right right and they're
going off this hadith for the last final
messenger that's what I said this is
like reviving the Sunnah the way of all
the messengers of Jesus who we love and
revere is one of the mightiest
messengers ever sent to mankind Abraham
Moses you can't be a Muslim unless you
believe and love them and problem homage
is being the last and final messenger
and in line to these messengers who by
the way I mean as I was mentioned they
came to the same message worship the one
creator nothing's worthy worship except
him and in the teachings we see in all
their teachings we see this similarity
and the Prophet Muhammad when he was
asked which charity is the best he
replied that which is given while you
fear poverty mmm Wow so this is given
being shown he's illustrating this soon
this way in his book let's correlate
this with what his grandfather said so
now we have the hadith we
image of the the soldier giving and we
have what his grandfather said the honor
the loyalty the importance of the faith
of the Muslims in their daily lives and
there's just so many beautiful stories
in this book the unknown fallen one of
the other ones that's just very very
impressive to me was the story that Luke
told me and it's in the book about the
the Minister of War of France at the
time he basically issued a ruling he
sent out like a letter to the to the
army saying that when the Muslim soldier
is dying this is the Shahada this is the
testimony of faith and this is how you
say if they're dying
give them their last rites so that's
Shahada now don't lose your place over
for the night yet Muslims tune in it
that's what someone says to become a
Muslim that they bear witness what's in
their nature there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens and earth and Mohammed just like
Jesus Moses Abraham was a Messenger of
God that's that sure how the dedication
the testimonies that are teaching now
the because you know when we die Muslims
we want to have this on our tongue yes
right and it's something that we say
live it we want to have it in our
tongues we continuously say it now that
I continuously saying you're conscious
of your maker and that is what's
motivating you to be righteous they be
humble to be a good human being and give
that charity to help even when you're
starving yes you're giving it to the
people so you can earn your place in
paradise help people in our list of
their background their Creed their their
differences you know we don't hate
people we don't want to harm people we
want to benefit people even on this show
you do shows now about healthy living
what's the reasoning behind it right
someone could say this is a show about
religion why are you talking about
healthy living without even saying it I
know that for a fact that you tie this
to the religion it goes back yeah it
goes back to consciousness of the
creator to Islam okay so you have the
consciousness but then why are you
sharing it why you benefit humanity and
if you benefit okay so similarly here we
have the French Minister of War saying
look these are our brothers in arms
these are our comrades
they've been loyal they've done what
they're supposed to do give them the
testimony of faith this is how you say
so Luke was sharing a story where you
would have priests rabbis and Imams
they had like an agreement amongst
themselves we're gonna give the last
rites to this whatever irregardless of
the soldier
faith this is their last moments on
earth let's give them their last rites
so that's why for me this is as a
student of this and as Luke has also
said on behalf of the organization this
is a political this is not about any
superpower not about any country not
about any agenda for him as he was
touched by the story of his grandfather
he wants to give life to the stories of
all these fallen soldiers and this is
why he's embarked on this on this
mission and honestly it touches my heart
that someone has preserved not only
Islamic history Muslim history but our
shared history I grew up in this country
with a lot of Christian friends who
helped me a lot they fed me you know we
were friends we go to their houses they
feed you you're you're physically in
their house their parents say nice
things to you spend time with them and
sometimes we forget about these bonds
right we're not talking about bonding
over doing bad things
partying drinking and these happy things
but you know being kind to each other
helping each other
putting roof over each other's heads
feeding each other these are these are
honorable things and sometimes we forget
like look Luke is a Christian his
grandfather was a Christian
we got a dispel this narrative that
people who are not of our faith are bad
necessarily right Luke is a good person
he's a very good person in my eyes I
never met his grandfather
I think his grandfather for doing this
work for a writing that letter so in
this book we have so many stories about
loyalty about brotherhood sisterhood
honor integrity there's a story and
there's a picture I think in it
somewhere around here about the there's
a picture of French nurses and they're
basically standing next to like Muslim
soldiers and they're smiling so let's
put this in picture let's put it in
perspective white French nurses with
darker North African and darker Indian
soldiers with their you know Islamic
prayer hats and they're longer garments
there and everybody's happy so this is
not in the essence where you have
someone compromising their Deen
compromising their their loyalty to
their Creator first and foremost and now
they start like okay well worship how
you worshiping one day and then we'll
flip it the other day no these are men
who are committed to
worshipping the creator not the creation
house but go ahead but there could but
but now when there's justice when
they're seeing and just when they're
seeing injustice they're standing there
standing against it when they're seeing
people who need food they're feeding
them when they what we gonna say so this
is like you said not compromising the
religion for me this is the point that
is not compromising when you see people
that need help you help them when you
see people are hungry feed them right so
now what happens the wars raging people
are they've run out of medical supplies
as Luke has mentioned in the book and
he's told me in person and what do you
have you have the the he says the Indian
Muslims and the North African Muslims
sharing their knowledge of herbal
medicine with the French nurses and in
turn the French nurses were able to save
more lives because they ran out of
supplies so now you just have good
feelings you have respect honor you have
a lot of the French British allied
dignitaries a lot of the the members of
the the community at the time honoring
Muslims for their contributions right so
we have to remember and preserve this
history and I just think that look
there's so many stories there's there's
a picture in the book of a Christian
soldier and a Muslim soldier like arm in
arms this is beautiful this is beautiful
and you see that when the people were in
the trenches your real self comes out
and this is why the non Muslim soldiers
they honor the Muslim soldiers because
they saw that a lot of them were people
of value people of honor on the same
side we have to also appreciate like
look we have to appreciate someone who
is not a Muslim but is helping us
preserve our history mm-hmm so how would
you have someone's thinking like okay
you see a Christian soldier and a
Muslims soldier there's that there's
that that movie it's it's very it was
very popular where you had the
Communists coming in to invade what was
the name of it they were coming to
invade America and it's a very popular
movie and then you had you know you know
the people who are coming together to
fight off the foreign invaders so now
just painting a picture like let's say
you had Communist China coming to a
hack America now this is a good vision
where Muslims would stand together side
by side you know yes to defend and to
protect right I would I would hope in
here so absolutely you know and it is
also like he mentioned in his research I
don't know if the number was it was a
couple of thousand but there were a
couple of thousand American Muslim
soldiers that served for America and
World War one yeah you know so you had
they said millions of soldiers worldwide
for the Allied side yeah hundreds of
thousands from North Africa hundreds of
thousands from India
5,000 or so Muslim soldiers or maybe a
little bit less from the United States
so you have so many of these stories and
these people were Muslims too but Islam
is totally against an oppression of a
people being on the side of oppressors
no no no we cooperating goodness yeah
and there's a just righteous cause Islam
are part of it right and this story
again see one thing again I'm gonna
reiterate this is not a political story
this is not a story of any country any
organization this is the preservation of
the stories and lives of soldiers the
book is called the unknown fallen uh-huh
why is it a unknown and we're just
trying to preserve their history so that
is shared and known so I want I want you
the audience to look into this I'm
curious to know because we should be
learning history we should be knowing so
it's not least things don't repeat
themselves and we can benefit so I'm
curious to know what you guys have to
say what you think get involved in the
conversation and we're bringing this to
you to light to spark a conversation
because when you look at and and this is
also to help motivate that good that's
in all of us we're all born as we
believe as Muslims with that original
goodness good from the get-go from the
start but when you see it's it's sad to
watch you recently not too long ago you
had one of the largest marches in
history and in Poland Warsaw I believe
where they were pretty much the slogans
were pray for Islamic Holocaust did you
hear about this yes 60,000 people came
together under the banner now of we are
Christian but this does not represent
Christianity of course not so you have
this element that's out there
and under the disguise of Christianity
and now they obviously also don't know
this history they don't know really what
Islam is about you have a researcher
someone who's not Christian I mean not
Muslim he's Christian his father was a
devout Christian and now he's talking
about jihad he's talking he talks about
jihad in this book isn't it let's talk
about that for a second that was it's
early yeah around page so now this is
someone who's sincere he's a Christian
he's doing his research he's not just
going off hate rhetoric and ignorance
and what does he conclude what's he
talking about he mentioned some facts
that we would agree with hundred percent
and if we motivate those Christians Jews
people just who really want to know come
to a most to come to come to really
investigate and know he mentions these
facts you talk about that this is
mentioned in his book so point number
six he says it is forbidden in Islam to
kill the innocent point numbers
non-combatants right because I've heard
people argue like all innocent innocent
Muslims they know this is innocent
non-combatants number number seven it is
forbidden to kill livestock destroy can
you yeah he's talking about basically
the rules of engagement this is
important you know killing animals
destroying infrastructure he goes over
these important points that any Muslim
who knows the basics of Islam nowadays
you hear the things about Isis and you
know Qaeda and all these things you know
people doing opposite of Islam these
groups set up who who are a minority and
now the people try to make them as a
majority and now these people who are
killing actually more Muslims the whole
Muslim world has come as a consensus
against this 0.1 0.001 9 percent fringe
element and now this is what sparks
these protests in Poland in other parts
of Europe now someone does the research
and says no no this is what it's about
you follow me and then when we look and
you can you can comment from here when
people were behind on rules of
engagement we had those rules which
actually helped
have an impact on the Geneva Convention
Luke says something he says something
really interesting those I don't know
the Geneva Convention people some people
don't even know what that is it's
basically as far as I know a set of
rules or regulations that guide a guide
how you interact and work in war yes and
it's its rules that should be there
right they should yeah so Luke says that
but that was 19 what 49 that was after
World War 1 after what then they said
man we got to put some rules here missus
getting gruesome and ugly you know Luke
says Luke says something really
interesting he goes because of Islam or
you know because of Islamic teachings in
the Sunnah and what have you that you
kind of have the Geneva Conventions
before the Geneva Conventions we were
the Islam was the Geneva Convention
perfect form before that right but see
this is what's so important people is
that you get educated that you learn
that you don't let this hate and hate
preachers and teachers out there guides
and form your perception this is what's
dangerous this is what creates now this
another version of Isis that's being
created amongst these white supremacist
and and and and and and people like this
we don't we don't support any form of
extremism on any side we don't support
any form of hate mongering hate speech
everyone's here to live a peaceful
comfortable life we want to live in
tranquility we want to spread goodness
we want to talk about goodness mine we
talk about mindfulness healthy eating
worshiping the one creator alone right
things that hopefully lead to a good
life one thing that I want to point out
because of the things that you just read
why is it that there's so many
testimonies that Luke has captured in
this book from non Muslim soldiers
soldiers of arms in arms with the
Muslims that prays the Muslims it's
because of things like this Monday when
they interacted with the Muslims they
saw that they were living proofs of
these very things not extreme even-keel
charitable they you know I don't know
the story verbatim but there's a story
if there was like a chemical attack
during the war and a chemical attack on
the Allies and one of the Muslim allied
soldiers like it's like imagine this has
a slow-mo Hollywood scene right he runs
in trying to save the Allied soldiers I
mean this is amazing yeah where are
these stories now you know that reminds
me of the problem Hamid peace and
blessings be upon him last the final
muster said to me
where he's during his time there were
the anonymous and the pagan Arabs and
they were forming a coalition to stand
against injustice and he had commented
that if that was alive and going today I
would be part of it and this is what
we're talking about being part of those
social movements those movements that
are for spreading good exactly
protecting the downtrod the oppressed
this is what Islam is about another
point here is where you see in this
picture there's Muslims not compromising
their Dean look over here you have the
Christians here in the book they're
praying they're praying right they're
doing their thing as the prophet saw
some peace symbols to be upon him when
he had the dialogue with Christians he
would allow them to go ahead and pray in
the mosque right right right
he allowed them to worship how they
worship here you got Muslims worshiping
that you had them in such de you have
them in rows praying like Jesus prays
with their heads on the ground praising
the Creator the one Jesus called to and
praised the one God are we gonna say so
Luke Luke told me a fascinating story
and one of the members of this
organization is called The Forgotten
heroes foundation 1419 hiya
he has a video online where he's talking
about some of the stories and it's
amazing so we talk about the Christians
in the Jews this time also we have to
give credit to the you know the Sikhs
and the Hindus because they fought
alongside the Muslims as well so there's
an amazing story where the Germans built
a prisoner of war camp and they built a
mosque in Germany trying to curry favor
the Muslims over to their side and the
Hindus were being sent away to other
camps where the conditions were very bad
and they would die rather quickly so
according to Luke and from what I heard
from Leon the Muslims were teaching the
Hindus and just how to behave a little
out wordly act Muslim just so their
lives could be saved so again they're
saving the Hindus now the Muslims are
right is what the the Germans as far as
far as I know from the you know from
what Luke and Heian have told me but
again and I don't want to I see I don't
like see they when we say Germans we're
not picking on the German no there are
there are Muslims who are German I had
an interview with one of the far zealot
you know Islamophobes not too long ago
who was in that far that
movement of extremism hate and he
actually accepted Islam right well put
it in context we're just talking about
world war one we're just talking out
we're not talk about any group and again
just to reiterate this is not picking on
a certain class of PA political yeah
this is at that time yes it's in that
time and even now we're not promoting
any country any idea a lot
ideology and he'll only own ISM anything
yeah
even let's make it clear the book is not
quote-unquote a propagation tool for
Islam it's just giving a voice to
soldiers that their story has not been
preserved and even Luke would tell us it
is part of our effort to save the the
stories of these soldiers to save the
lives of these intense forms of
brotherhood sisterhood bonds of
friendship you have white brown black
Indian English there's stories of Somali
soldiers fighting for the Allies so many
of the screen I want to get Luke on the
show and then I want you guys to engage
with us
Luke would he engage with us I which
gamble I look at Luke Luke mr. Luke
farrier please come to this show I think
it would be great for you to come and as
far as I know Luke is willing to come on
the show the next time he's in America
yeah right now they are busy promoting
an event it's called singularity of
peace even look at the name singularity
of peace and you can go on singularity
of peace calm and what they're doing
it's it's a Muslim led initiative where
they're calling on hundreds of artists
to come to the event to basically talk
about peace make make forms of art about
peace about conflict and they're calling
these artists they're calling you know
young businessmen entrepreneurs they're
also going to have a section for Black
History Month in England again diversity
promotion of good values good material
and you know singularity of peace will
start I think in the second week of
September they can find out more
information on the website I think what
you put in the description there's also
the book the unknown fallen they can
find out about the book and unknown
fallen calm and the organization that is
behind this is called Forgotten heroes
foundation what a beautiful name The
Forgotten heroes
14:19 and I I look forward to
god-willing having Luke on the program
and just you guys I want to get you guys
involved to get your take on this is one
more thing before we conclude
another part on chapter 32 of the book
he talks about officers were surprised
he said the the people are not Muslim
they're surprised a member almost
submissively one who submits their will
to the crater to heaven if you've been
watching a detail you know that already
for those of our guys just tuning in
that's what it means
officers were surprised when Muslim
soldiers lecture them okay now they're
lecture reviving the Sunnah again look
at that lecture them about the fact that
captured prisoners of war would be taken
to a place that had been prepared for
them they should not harm them or
torture them with beating right style
torture look so you shouldn't torture
them beat them to harm them deprive them
of food and water leave them in the Sun
or in the cold can you imagine just I
mean just waterboarding and all these
things that debates on burn them with
fire or put them put covers over their
mouths ears and eyes and put them in
cages like animal it's not allowed in
Islam this is not allowed this is
against it teaches a problem Hamid peace
but even if you have these the insane
state whatever state doing it that
already exposes to you that this is not
a part of Islam they don't support those
rather and they should treat them with
kindness what we say he's talking about
this very important the rather they
should treat now this is the again paint
the picture in imagine is these are
Muslims teaching this to the not yet
Muslims on how they should treat the
prisoners that were just shooting at
them they're in conflict now they caught
them prisoners of war and they're
telling them rather they should treat
them with kindness and mercy and feed
them well amazing then he has a cold
here compassion as the basis of morality
and he also talks about something about
not separating the children from their
families oh man do we have what we have
going on today we got torture debates
should we not should we Islam is clear
on that he's got beautiful quotes in the
book from the Quran he's got a former
American presidents he's got a you know
there was an amazing quote he had from
Gandhi about humanity being humane so I
think the book is overall a positive
message let me ask you what do you
the book I mean I want I'm just I'm just
getting into it I'm you know I haven't
finished it completely but when I when I
see like I started off with when I see
the revival of the Sunnah the way of
Jesus Moses Abraham the teachings of
mercy and righteous is being highlighted
in a world now when we see so much hate
being perpetuate dividing us as humans
we're all brothers in humanity as
brothers in faith but then you have
brothers in humanity now if we're
brothers we shouldn't be killing one
another or or hating each other and
Islam doesn't expose that but the thing
now is you see that in Europe you see
this huge movement of it it's all based
on on on false propaganda on on hate
right and ignorant of people but when
you see these things now that are being
written by Christians that are being
historical facts that are being brought
to light this needs to be in the hands
as the people like that so they can
rethink their position be like hold on
man
people don't like being lied to and many
people the majority of these hate
preachers teachers they're lying to the
people so what I always so people like
you said many people don't like being
lied to and from my experience as an
American Americans are very open-minded
yes yes they love truth and honesty I'm
one of them brother and we're one of
them we're one of them yes so and they
look they love dialogue and interaction
and this is why we love that that's when
I met Luke I said man this is this is
from God
imagine at this time a non Muslim openly
non Muslim and we have to point that out
promoting this the the saving of Islamic
history the saving of these stories of
Muslims Christians Hindus Jews seeks
truth it's the truth and that's why it
isn't just promoting the truth have to
do with religion at that point he has to
do with the fact that this is true and
you see he's made it his life's work he
this makes him tick more than it makes
most of us tick yeah yeah and I've met
him once when he came to America he was
at Harvard he has some some programs
online you know from other members of
his organization and they're doing this
event I wish I was there singularity of
peace so many people are gonna come the
local the local group the local
government as far as I know in London
it's in Hammersmith they're behind it
they support it you
artists young entrepreneurs and also you
know I told you last time I was on the
show that I do mentorship imagine this
now they're calling young artists
they're calling young entrepreneurs
they're giving away some of the stalls
for free this is just support
encouragement dialog this is what we
should be doing this is what we should
be about this is how dialogue takes
place this is how we impart an impact
positivity this is how you sleep better
at night people can tick something will
get you moving and some people are
driven by that fuel of hate and that you
are not falling asleep well with that
going to bed agitated aggravated and all
pumped up with all of this hate rhetoric
that's not gonna you're not gonna sleep
well brothers and sisters no way but the
truth when someone is dedicated to
something good a noble cause it's it's
premium unleaded that it's it's that
fuel that really motivates you and
brings positive results promoting peace
love mercy just as promoting these
qualities that bring mankind together
rather than dividing us I think there's
no follow up to what you just said I
mean that's what that's what life is
about it's about living a life of
purpose sleeping better at night by
partaking by getting involved by
bettering the community that's why I
love what you're doing and I think
you're talking somewhere tonight about
healthy living and healthy eating I mean
what else is there in life I taught ESL
for numerous years and when you teach
ESL to those that come to this country
and you see the hunger and thirst that
they have to learn the language to
become a part of the culture to then in
turn help by getting better jobs by
helping their children what else is
there right you have to get involved you
have to partake in in higher projects
and this is why I'm happy to be involved
in this project because this is again a
political a religious even though it's
is highlighting the contributions of the
Muslims but it's such a noble effort in
such a noble endeavor I think Luke I
think hyeyeon I think my friend Hameed I
think the rest of the team
I think the Forgotten heroes foundation
if you want the book unknown fallen calm
singularity of peace calm for this event
that is coming up in Hammersmith London
and I'll end with this this is the
beginning of the book and we'll end with
that there's a quote that says we may
have different religions different
languages different colored skin but we
all belong to one human race for any
Muslim now he thinks of the verse in the
Quran where God Almighty is talking
about that we've made you into different
nations and tribes hmm speaking of
different having different colors
speaking different languages but it was
for a noble purpose that you know each
other not that you despise and hate each
other so let's get rid of the hate
people thank you very much for thank you
being with us you have the information
let's create I'm learning more about
this and I wanted to bring it to your
guys attention tell me what you think
look into it if you have some questions
for Luke when we get them God willing on
the show send them in or make sure you
subscribe right now and on the
notification bell so you get that show
God willing when it comes out and let's
be peaceful
let's be people who foster goodness not
hate you got to cut to hate eradicate it
and promote things that will help you
sleep better at night we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you
Salaam like please subscribe to the
video follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]